je pense que c'est important de toujours
surveiller l'apparition de résistance
dans la mesure où le parasite s'adapte
constamment aux traitements que l'on
donne aux patients
[Musique]
mais j'étais peut-être destiné à
travailler dans le domaine scientifique
parce que déjà
mon père il a fait des études physique
donc il est docteur en physique ma mère
est médecin mais de grande sœur qui lune
et médecin l'autre est ingénieur Telecom
la séance était un petit peu pour moi
aujourd'hui de plus en plus on observe
que lorsqu'on prend le traitement avec
le paludisme il y a plusieurs cas de
figure il y en a qui guérissent tout de
suite il y en a chez qui ça prend un
petit peu de temps pour guérir il y en a
qui ne guérissent pas on est obligé de
changer de traitement au moins ce que je
regarde c'est les causes de cette note
guérison ou de cette guérison tardive
chez
les patients infecté mais je m'intéresse
à ce qui se passe chez le parasite parce
que le parasite il a ce qu'on appelle
des jeunes qui peut entraîner la
résistance et qui dit résistance dit
finalement
la survie du parasite malgré justement
la prise de médicaments donc moi je
regarde est-ce que le parasite a des
gènes de résistance associé à tel ou tel
autre médicament utilisé ce que je fais
également c'est que je prends ce
parasite la
et je le mets au contact finalement du
médicament et j'observe pour certaines
molécules notamment la chloroquine qui
avant et est utilisé comme traitement
effectivement à force d'utilisation les
parasites sens de plus en plus résistant
et actuellement on décrit beaucoup de
cas de résistance à la l'artémisinine
et on est encore en train d'étudier mais
je pense que le fait que les industries
pharmaceutiques soit sur la recherche de
nouveaux médicaments n'est pas étranger
à cette situation documentation des
résistances
le paludisme c'est quelque chose de très
important parce que c'est la maladie
parasitaire la plus meurtrière
actuellement toutes les deux minutes il
y a environ une personne qui meurent de
paludisme et nous savons que l'Afrique
subsaharienne c'est plus de 90 % des cas
et donc il m'a paru assez naturel de me
diriger vers cette maladie là c'est vrai
qu'il y a d'autres maladies mets le
paludisme est de loin la plus meurtrière
notamment chez les femmes enceintes et
chez les enfants et donc ça m'a beaucoup
plus intéressé dans ce cadeau
le but de cette recherche que je mène
actuellement c'est justement pour
pouvoir fournir un outil d'analyse au
programme national de lutte contre le
paludisme sur l'utilisation des
traitements traitement curatif comme
traitement préventif est-ce qu'ils sont
utiliser à bon escient et est-ce que ça
vaut la peine de continuer à les
utiliser parce que c'est à partir de
recherche de ce type que qu'il avait été
décidé d'arrêter d'utiliser la
chloroquine en traitement curatif qu'il
avait été décidé d'arrêter d'utiliser
la sulfadoxine-pyriméthamine en
traitement curatif
nous nous sommes convaincus que la
science est un domaine auquel nous
appartenons nous faisons tu pourrais de
véritables scientifique met autour de
nous on a souvent des des jeunes filles
des jeunes femmes qui abandonnent en
cours de route et ça ce sont des
phénomènes quand même que nous pouvons
combattre ce ne sont pas des gens qui
n'ont pas les compétences pour les
capacités de le faire mais qui pour des
raisons y associer notamment
au préjugé sans contrainte d'abandonner
de laisser tomber pour laisser la place
aux hommes
allons-nous qui finalement arrivant
jusqu'à faire un petit bout de chemin si
on a les capacités de s'engager de
continuer de motiver d'autres personnes
pourquoi pas